selena gomez just wants you to know
she's doja cat's biggest fan
crazy over the weekend the 29 year old
triple threat shared a clip to tick tock
wrapping every single word from a verse
on doja's hit track get into it yeah
impressive right we hope everybody
enjoys it well it gets even better
and just in case there was any question
selena captioned the post quote i love
doja like a lot i love it and when it
caught up with the woman singer ahead of
the mtv vmas last month she opened up
about all the love and support she's
received from her fans i'm happy that
i'm able to express myself in a
different way with a different style
i've been doing a lot of hip-hop and i'm
down to
you know explore other other facets
and i think it's going to be exciting
for my fans i'm very very happy that
people
are supporting and enjoying what i'm
doing as for selena she's quickly
becoming a fan favorite on tick tock it
was so much fun last month she danced
with her little sister gracie to lizzo
and cardi b's rumors and get this lizzo
dewetted the video on stage while
performing at the global citizen live
benefit concert
selena and gracie also served up major
cuteness while taking on the viral linda
and heather trends
[Music]
[Applause]
and to send you off i'll leave you with
my personal fave selena totally getting
trolled by her little sister while
trying to learn how to use the tick tock
gap
you embarrass me
i just deleted the little tip
[Music]